George Floyd was laid to rest today but
his impact will live on tonight Oprah
and Gayle King will host two TV specials
that will address the ongoing fury over
his death and the urgent calls for
change watching the life seep from
George
Floyd's body caused at the universal
shock people are angry and they are
demanding change how do we protect
ourselves survive and thrive
I know the me on the neck is so symbolic
of so much how are you handling things
it's it's been a while now it's now
going into month number three I cannot
sleep I feel a constant state of worry
and angst I mean listen we went from
kovat the pandemic of Kovac and now
dealing with the horrible murder of
George Floyd and all the repercussions
of that Jamie Foxx and Channing Tatum
were among the hundreds who gathered in
Houston today for George Floyd's funeral
Jamie posted this photo of them arriving
by bus as the black lives matter
conversation continues to stir deep
emotions I mean I'm not worried about
well my son was 33 years old walking his
friggin dog in the neighborhood you know
because I think everybody is on such a
hair-trigger these days I also think
that it is important that we know that
you and Oprah are leading conversations
about this about what is going on in
this country yeah you know Kevin this is
funny because I was talking here I said
you know CBS is gonna be doing the
primetime special about that she goes
I'm doing a primetime special - I go
when - you're on time special she said
Tuesday when's yours I said Tuesday
Kevin there is a hunger for information
about this and that to me is very
satisfying very gratifying
Gayle's justice for all special airs
tonight on CBS Oprah special is called
where do we go from here and it features
David O yellow oh who played Martin
Luther King jr. in the movie Selma I
have spent so much
of the last two weeks crying and and one
of the moments where that began was when
I went to speak to my son and I didn't
have the words because George Floyd
wasn't resisting arrest so it's not like
saying to my son put your hands on the
dash don't be confrontational come home
alive Floyd's death has helped spark
change CBS News correspondent Michelle
Miller was at the funeral today what is
the feeling of the mood in Houston you
have people who are highly emotional
they want to make sure that this moment
in time is not closed after George Floyd
is buried today this is something
everybody should care about because we
are all human beings people are angry
and they are demanding change and that
is a good thing
Gail and I ended things on a lighter
note and her hope for another type of
change today I just said you know I've
been in my home what if I did the news
from your guest house is that an option
Mull that over and she said yes I could
come so believe me I am thinking about
that
[Music]